this video is brought to you by manscape
the brand dedicated to men's
below-the-belt grooming and hygiene go
to manscape comm and use the promo code
wisecrack 20 to get 20% off free
shipping and a free gift what's up guys
jared here to talk about pop culture's
greatest call to arms for slackers
office space the beloved 1999 film about
hating your job your boss and your early
morning commute has inspired and
comforted the souls of many a bored
administrative assistant at first glance
office space seems to be hilarious ode
to white collar laziness and Michael
bulb Michael Bolton that's me Wow is
that your real name yeah but we think
there's something else going on that may
explain why the film has remained
relevant for over 20 years it's because
office space embodies what some believe
to be the most radical form of
revolution and we don't mean arson let's
find out what all this has to do with a
Dan Harmon look like in this week's
wisecrack edition on the philosophy of
office space and spoilers ahead for
office space and a 19th century short
story by Herman Melville but before we
get into it I want to give a shout out
to manscaped manscaped is well it's
exactly what it sounds like it's
grooming and hygiene for your man parts
and I don't know about you but cutting
my face with the razor really sucks and
as bad as that is it's way worse when
you're dealing with the area of your
body that makes life worth living
manscaped will ease your worries with
their perfect package 2.0 kit which
features the lawnmower 2.0 a waterproof
trimmer that has skin-safe technology to
make sure there are no Nick's or snags
when you include the peak hygiene plan
as part of your purchase a replacement
trimmer blade will be delivered to your
door every three months so you have the
most hygienic shave possible they'll
also send you a free mystery gift each
time and the Shedd travel bag totally
free so no more using your niece's pink
arts and crafts scissors
you deserve something legit and safe
you'll get 20% off free shipping and the
free gifts when you use the code
wisecrack 20 at manscape calm
once again that's manscape calm promo
code wisecrack 20 and now back to
show our guys let's go into a little
recap Peter Gibbons is a dissatisfied
programmer at an oppressively generic
tech firm where he spends his days
getting nagged by his boss at his
girlfriend's request he agrees to see an
occupational hypnotherapist who puts
Peter in a trance and then promptly dies
of a heart attack Peters left in a state
of blissful non giver fury which he then
pairs with flip-flops and heads into the
office when the firm's new consultants
meet a suddenly chillaxed Peter they're
so impressed by his boss like attitude
that they literally make him one so
you're gonna fire Michael and Samir and
you're gonna give me more money Wow once
Peters promoted he and his buddies plot
to rob their company and things go a
little nuts now for the purposes of this
video we're not gonna be talking much
about the scam that fuels the second
half of the film rather we're focusing
on the film's legacy as a cultural
artifact that speaks to employee
disaffection and general workplace
ambivalence people don't proudly display
an office space poster to express their
desire to steal millions from their
corporate overlords well maybe that but
mostly to encapsulate their fantasy of
showing their boss how little they care
to understand why office space is so
intoxicating we need to take a super
brief look at the history of the office
as a social construct but not the
physical office but say the office of
the mayor as philosopher Giorgio Agamben
recounts in his book Opus Dei and
archaeology of duty the idea of the
office really began with the
institutionalization of the Catholic
Church if a priest tells you to do a
hundred Hail Marys well that could just
be some Rando arbitrarily making up a
number but coming from a guy holding an
official office with ties to the
official church it gives us order more
legitimacy which is all well and good
but this construct of the office has had
rippling effects scholar benjamin louis
robinson builds off a combin by
suggesting that from the beginning this
imbued the culture of work with a
spiritual and transcendent element by
early modern history robinson writes the
notion of the efficacy of the office was
generalized
into a moral concept that defined the
very agency of human beings doing your
work wasn't just about a paycheck it was
about duty and purpose now
you're very Eunice is defined by what
you do for work and how effectively you
do it now this may seem like a given but
that just shows how thoroughly our
society buys into the idea in this way
our very conception of ourselves is
defined by our obligations as employees
which sucks the phenomenon of a person's
work subsuming their identity is pretty
clearly illustrated in office space when
Peter is casually asked by his boss to
work not just one but both days of the
weekend I'm gonna need you to go ahead
and come in tomorrow so if you could be
here around 9:00 that would be great
okay oh oh and I almost forgot
I'm also gonna need you to go ahead and
come in on Sunday too okay because why
would he have a life outside of his job
similarly for his soon-to-be boo Joanna
every part of her identity is regulated
by her waitressing job her Flair or
assortment of buttons and patches might
seem to be showcasing her personality
but we soon learned that such displays
of individuality are actually mandated
by her boss we need to talk about your
Flair here her very performance of
selfhood is tightly controlled by her
job so we have this monolithic
definition of the office as a place
where we not only accomplish our life's
work but our lives as such is it any
wonder we might come to resent the very
institution indeed the slacker lifestyle
didn't begin with your cool incense
burning ant in fact we see a distinctly
office space Ian brand of slacktivism
fermenting an author Herman Melville's
iconic 1848 short story Bartleby the
Scrivener a story of Wall Street which
we have opted to illustrate visa vie a
delightfully corny 1969 short film
adaptation because those eyebrows
Melville's story chronicles through the
eyes of a bewildered lawyer the exploits
of his newest employee a scribe named
Bartleby who after working industriously
for several weeks copying lengthy law
documents suddenly decides that he
doesn't feel like it anymore his
vernacular choice has become
immortalized in literature and pop
culture when asked to do anything he
doesn't want to do
Bartleby simply says I prefer not to
this starts with not wanting to
proofread his copy then escalates to
refusing to copy at all and eventually
culminates in him refusing to leave the
law office where he just plain prefers
to hang out all night while quietly
staring out the window the similarities
between Bartleby and Peter's initial
narratives are not insignificant both
are low-level employees working for
passive-aggressive bosses both labor and
claustrophobic solitude doing work they
don't care about both appear to have a
distaste for bureaucracy and both will
eventually seek solace in the great
outdoors to varying degrees of happiness
but we'll get to that later most
importantly both turn their offices
upside down when they decide to stop
working but let's start by looking at
their defining characteristic the choice
not to work according to Robinson
Bartleby's refusal to act is not a mere
inaction rather by preferring not to act
Bartleby ventures from sheer passivity
into what he calls a second-order
passivity which is performed in its
ineffectiveness he and Peter as well
choose to be useless in the very place
where effectiveness is the highest
calling so inexplicable as Peters
behavior and his apparent unwillingness
to do his damn job that the
uncomprehending chummy consultants
decided must be evidence of superiority
he is indeed too good for his work and
thus should be promoted Peters inaction
becomes even more radical when
considered with the culture of office
politics as Robinson puts it the modern
office is the space that ensures that it
is easy to do one's duty free from the
burden of your conscience or the
consequences of your actions when your
work is inherently disengaging he adds
petty conflicts and trivial
confrontations seem to take on epic
proportions this he notes would
eventually manifest delightfully as
office politics or the cultural science
of why the hell Cassady choose her Greek
salad so damn loud office politics are
on full display in office space whether
in the form of Peter's boss claiming the
best parking spot or poor Milton being
separated from his beloved stapler and
relegated to increasingly worse desk
assignments
refusing to engage in or even recognize
office politics as when Peter steals his
boss's precious parking spot stops
dressing up and comes in when he feels
like it
a newly Zen Peter acts like an anarchist
agitating against the very institution
of the office Bartleby and Peter bring
something else profound to the office as
identified in the famous last line of
Melville's story after Bartleby
inevitably starves to death in prison
after preferring not to eat his former
boss exclaims Robinson argues that this
line can be read as a recognition of the
fact that Bartleby and all his perverse
peculiarity is what humanity would look
like in an office were it ever to make
such an appearance in other words for an
office to function it must strip us of
said humanity in Bartleby's refusal to
do boring grunt work his desire to do
nothing and his complete rejection of
the mundane eighties of office life he
displays an unwillingness to suppress
his human desires for the sake of
official duties similarly trance now
Peter seems to embody the selfish
pleasure-seeking impulses that unite us
in humanity he acts on base human
desires in a world where everyone else
simply ignores or represses them beneath
the veneer of earnest goodwill and
productivity a human version of Peter
looks like a guy who actually dates
someone he likes a guy who watches
kung-fu movies a guy who smashes a
faulty printer just for the heck of it
it's worth noting that these two
slackers are backed by one influential
philosopher slavo Dziedzic Dziedzic is a
major proponent of Bartleby style of
political action and is one of the
modernity 'he's biggest advocates for
saying i would prefer not to - well
everything indeed
in action he argues can be incredibly
active jiseok wrote in his book violence
that sometimes doing nothing is the most
violent thing to do if this sounds
ridiculous you've clearly never been
ghosted but why is you jack wearing the
jersey of literature's greatest slacker
to understand that we first need to
contextualize gix perspective on
contemporary society this argument goes
like this we live in a world of economic
and political deadlock for multinational
corporations of all the power and change
feels like
impossible this is the net result of the
20th century which was a time of intense
action various countries experimented
with socialism fascism communism hippy
ISM bad-hair ISM every ISM they could
think of it brought change much of it
not great and resulted in our
present-day world in jiseok's mind all
that action may have been misguided or
as he puts it
maybe we tried to change the world too
quickly and so we're stuck with status
quo capitalism rampant inequality the
Amazon on fire and caste not shutting up
about essential oils along those lines
jiseok tends to think that despite
capitalism's numerous flaws we don't yet
have an alternative worth actual Isaac
as a result any activity that we do take
is not only doomed to fail but actually
risks aiding the powers that be G Jack
warns against engaging in localized acts
whose ultimate function is to make the
system run more smoothly he cautions
that rather than fearing passivity we
should strenuously work to avoid pseudo
activity that is the urge to be active
to participate simply as a way to mask
the pointlessness of your actions that
right there it describes the office work
both Bartleby and Peter rail against in
refusing to copy legal documents or
print out cover letters for boring
reports they are boldly asserting a
truth that only doing nothing can
communicate that the office work which
once dominated their lives is actually
totally meaningless while it may be
tempting to tell your boss off that may
only lead to new HR rules you may
complain of overwork but they'll just
add a pool table and call themselves
heroes or you may want to burn the place
down but that will only put a fat
insurance check in your boss's pocket
all these things only make the system
stronger the most radical form of
rebellion may be to do nothing lastly
it's important to look at the ending of
both office space and Bartleby what is
the net result of each main character's
defiance an office space the offices
burnt down and Peter takes a job
cleaning up the refuge with his
next-door neighbor
listen so bad huh making bucks get an
exercise working outside in retreating
from office life entirely he sought a
return to blue-collar labor getting as
close to a pastoral paradise of sweat
calluses hard work and tangible results
as modern city life might allow for
Bartleby his refusal to leave the office
eventually lands him in prison where he
spends all his time hanging out in the
courtyard fittingly enough he too has
escaped the grind and fled to the
outdoors sure he starves himself to
death but at least he didn't die at his
desk right so what do you guys think
does your effectiveness at work or
school define you and how do you feel
about that do you fantasize about doing
nothing like jiseok Peter and Bartleby
or is preferring not to just a cop out
let us know what you think in the
comments thanks to all our awesome
patrons for supporting the channel and
our podcasts go ahead and hit that
subscribe button and as always thanks
for watching guys peace
[Music]